the world together almost almost
non-stop
on
the most immediate matter at hand
russia's aggression against ukraine but
on a multiplicity of other things
because our countries are joined
in having
shared interests across virtually every
significant issue
before the world now we were just in
brussels uh last week with ministers
from our fellow nato allies the g7 the
european union
uh focused particularly on continuing
what has been extraordinarily close
coordination and cooperation in response
to moscow's unprovoked unjustified and
increasingly brutal war in ukraine
we and our teams are in almost constant
contact
as we calibrate a united response not
just between our two nations
which have a long history of working
hand in hand
through the special relationship but
with allies and partners across europe
and indeed beyond
at least in my experience
of doing this for nearly 30 years i
cannot remember a time where we've seen
such unity in the transatlantic
relationship both in policy
and in principle
uh we're united in strengthening our
security assistance to ukraine for its
heroic defenders
we're united in increasing our
assistance the people of ukraine
who are suffering grievously due to the
growing humanitarian catastrophe
inflicted upon them by moscow's invasion
and we're united in our efforts to raise
the costs on the kremlin for waging this
ongoing war of choice
which has already displaced more than 2
million ukrainians
earlier this week prime minister johnson
announced an additional 175 million
pounds in aid to ukraine bringing the
uk's total support during the crisis i
believe to approximately 400 million
pounds
this includes direct assistance for the
ukrainian government to pay the salaries
of ukraine's public sector employees who
are keeping critical
services running where they haven't been
bombed by the russians
the ukraine was one of the uk was one of
the first european countries to send
defensive lethal security assistance to
ukraine and the government has imposed
severe financial sanctions on president
putin his inner circle russian oligarchs
and others who enable and fuel this
aggression
just days ago uh the house of commons
passed a new economic crime bill aimed
at making it easier to sanction groups
of corrupt individuals and harder for
those trying to hide their money in the
uk
yesterday in the latest of the many
steps that we've taken together
to hold the kremlin accountable
president biden banned all imports of
russian oil liquefied natural gas and
coal
prime minister johnson committed to ban
all imports of russian oil by the end of
2022
we're also united in calling on the
kremlin to immediately allow ukrainian
civilians to safely depart the cities
and towns of ukraine that are besieged
by russian forces
every country has a responsibility to
join us in pressing moscow to do this
this is not the time to equivocate by
calling on both sides to allow civilians
in ukraine cities to leave safely
doing so obviously obfuscates the basic
facts around why these corridors are
necessary and who is blocking them
russia invaded ukraine without
justification russian forces now
encircle multiple ukrainian cities after
having destroyed much of their critical
infrastructure leaving people without
water without electricity without access
to food and medicine
and russia's relentless bombardment
including of civilians trying to flee
prevents people from safely escaping the
hellish conditions that they've created
the kremlin's proposals to create
humanitarian corridors leading into
russia and belarus
are absurd
it's offensive to suggest the ukrainian
people should seek refuge from the very
government that has demonstrated such
disregard for their lives
the civilians who were able to escape
yesterday through one of those corridors
from sumi uh to paltova another city in
ukraine
shows that this is possible
but it must be allowed to happen on a
much broader scale
it's not only in europe where the united
states of the uk are working together to
address threats to international peace
and security
we also share a grave concern about
iran's nuclear advances
together we discussed our work to
achieve a mutual return to compliance
with a joint comprehensive plan of
action the so-called iran nuclear
agreement
either way
we are committed to ensuring that iran
can never acquire a nuclear weapon
on northern ireland president biden has
been steadfast in his support for the
belfast good friday agreement which he
views as a historic achievement that
must be protected to ensure the peace
stability and prosperity of people in
northern ireland
the united states continues to support
both sides efforts to engage in
productive dialogue to resolve
differences
over the northern ireland protocol
before handing it over to liz let me
just make one final point
it's not just the british government
that's stepping up to help ukraine we're
also seeing incredible solidarity and
compassion
from the british people
people like khalid almayat
who is leading a local campaign to buy
second-hand ambulances and drive them
packed with supplies to humanitarian
responders at ukraine's border
people like yorkshire resident magdalena
timmin who on the second night of
russia's invasion
sent a message to a facebook group
called polish mums of leads appealing
for donations to help people in ukraine
within days she'd received enough to
fill three
18-wheelers i believe one reason we're
seeing such an outpouring of support
from the british people
is because they've been through
something similar
the harrowing blitz during world war ii
inflicted colossal suffering on the
country's people killing more than sixty
thousand british civilians wounding
eighty six thousand more
it's impossible to see the images of
people seeking refuge in keys metro in
2022 and not think of those
who sheltered in the london underground
in 1942.
the grit the compassion the
determination that britain's exhibited
eight decades ago
that inspired the world is exactly what
we see in the people of ukraine today
and it's why we need to stand with them
with that liz over to you
well thank you very much tony and it's
great to be here with my friend and ally
secretary blinken and we've certainly
seen a lot of each other around the
capitals of europe over the last week
working very closely with our allies
putin's illegal invasion of ukraine
is causing immense pain and suffering
yet he is not making the progress he
planned
since the build-up on the border the
united kingdom and the united states
have led work in the g7 and through nato
to challenge putin's aggression
before the invasion
the united states and the uk
called out his playbook of false flags
attempts to install a puppet regime in
kiev
and fake provocations
we worked with our g7 allies to warn
that he would face severe costs
and determined ukrainian people we have
surprised putin with our unity and the
toughness of our sanctions
hitting the banks the ships the planes
the oligarchs and the oil and gas
revenues
and the brave ukrainian people have
surprised him with their determination
and their leadership
now is not the time to let up
putin must fail
we know from history that aggressors
only understand one thing and that is
strength
we know that if we don't do enough now
other aggressors around the world will
be emboldened
and we know that if putin is not stopped
in ukraine there will be terrible
implications for european and global
security
we would be sending a message that
sovereign nations can simply be trampled
on
so we must go further and faster in our
response
we must double down on our sanctions
that includes a full swift ban and the
g7 ending its use of russian oil and gas
the united states the united kingdom
this week announced our plans to stop
importing russian oil and the eu have
announced their plans to reduce their
dependency too
we want to encourage a wider group of
countries to get on board with our
sanctions effort
141 countries voted against russian
aggression at unga
and we must continue to supply defensive
weapons to ukraine
i'm proud that the united kingdom was
the first european country to do that
and i welcome the decision of germany
and japan and many others to send
military aid
since the end of the cold war
we took our eye off the ball
but we are now stepping up together
and we must never let down our guard
again
we're determined to keep strengthening
nato
and urge all allies to increase their
investment we must accelerate nato's
modernization
and deepen our cooperation on tech and
cyber
we will end strategic dependence on
authoritarian regimes for our energy and
for other vital resources
and we will step up our work to build
economic and security alliances around
the world
including with india and the gulf
nations to further isolate russia
we'll keep working to bring more
countries into the orbit of those who
believe in the sovereignty of nation
and by playing by the rules
the war in ukraine is a struggle for the
future of freedom and self-determination
we must not rest until putin fails in
ukraine and the country's sovereignty is
restored thank you
we'll now turn to questions taking two
questions per side uh alternating we'll
start with kylie atwood of cnn
good afternoon or morning thank you for
doing this um
secretary blinken yes or no uh do you
believe it's possible to get the
ukrainians mig-29 fighter jets if so
when and how
nothing for my friend okay we'll go to
you um
first as we've said uh
the decision about whether to transfer
any equipment
to um our friends in ukraine is
ultimately one that each government will
decide for itself and has to make
we're in very close consultation with
allies and partners
about the ongoing security assistance to
ukraine
because in fact
i think
what we're seeing is that poland's
proposal shows that there are some
complexities that the issue uh presents
uh when it comes to providing uh
security assistance we have to make sure
that we're doing it in the right way you
heard from the department of defense
uh just yesterday about the particular
proposal the prospect of fighter jets at
the disposal of the united states
government
departing from a u.s nato base in
germany to fly into airspace contested
with russia
over ukraine raises some serious
concerns for the entire nato alliance so
we have to work through the specifics of
these things
going forward and it's not
simply clear to us that there is a
substantive rationale for doing it in
the way that was
put forward yesterday so
what we're doing right now is continuing
to consult very closely with uh with
poland with other nato allies on this
uh and the logistical challenges
that it presents
together with poland
as well as with the uk and many of our
other partners
as we've noted we have provided
extraordinary support to uh to ukraine
and to those defending it from the
russian aggression
support that has been used extremely
effectively by ukrainian defenders
support that will continue uh in the
days weeks and months ahead
just
yesterday with the supplemental
legislation being put forward we have an
additional 6.5 billion dollars in
security assistance that's now on tap
just from the united states
for ukraine and that will of course
include
uh the very kinds of things that they
need to effectively defend ukraine
against russian aggression
thanks and and just to clarify basically
what you're saying is there is a
creative way to get them these fighter
jets possibly but you haven't figured
out the pathway forward on that and then
my second question for both of you is um
with ukrainian deaths mounting
right now what more can the u.s and the
uk do
would either country be open
to considering the possibility of a
limited no-fly zone over uh humanitarian
corridors uh to be set up in the country
thank you
so
first of all in answer to your question
the united kingdom
has been first of all supplying
defensive weapon to weaponry into
ukraine and in fact we have been working
with other allies across the world to
help get that defensive weaponry into
ukraine so we've been supplying
anti-tank weapons
today our defense secretary announced
that we will now be supplying air
defense systems to address the specific
issue the ukrainians face
which is
air defense so we believe that the best
way
of tackling this threat is to help
the ukrainians with the star streak air
defense systems that we will be
supplying
on the issue of a no-fly zone
of course it's important and i
completely support what tony has said
about protecting humanitarian corridors
and calling on russia to respect those
genuine humanitarian corridors i.e ones
that don't lead into russia or belarus
but the reality is that setting up a
no-fly zone
would lead to a direct confrontation
between nato and russia and that is not
what we are looking at what we are
looking at is making sure that the
ukrainians are able to defend their own
country with the best possible selection
of anti-tank weapons and
anti-air defense systems and i agree
with everything that the foreign
secretary said
kylie we need to we need to move on
could we have sarah smith at the bbc
please
thank you very much
uh after the direct strike on a
children's hospital in mario paul
president zielinski is asking
you both and nato to stop the killings
close the skies he says and that if you
don't you're an accomplice to terror how
do you explain to him that there is no
possibility of a no-fly zone in these
circumstances
well as i've said sarah
the best way to help protect the skies
is through anti-air weaponry which the
uk is now going to be supplying to
ukraine that's what the defense
secretary announced earlier today and of
course the attack on the hospital
is absolutely abhorrent
reckless and appalling and the uk is at
the forefront of supplying humanitarian
aid into ukraine
we've already pledged 220 million of
humanitarian aid our our deck appeal has
now reached 130 million
which is the largest amount it's ever
achieved since 2004 so the british
people are full square behind the people
of ukraine and we're doing all we can to
support
um and i would just add as we already
said first
we both
uh our governments both our people both
have
tremendous admiration
for president zielinski uh for his
entire team for the ukrainian people
that they represent
but the courage they've shown
the strength the determination the
dignity faced with this
russian onslaught is extraordinary
and it's powerfully moving i think to
people around the world
if i were in president zielinski's
position i'm sure i would be asking for
everything possible
in his mind to
help the ukrainian people and as the
foreign secretary and i have laid out
both of our countries and so many others
have done
extraordinary things to make sure that
the ukrainians have in their hands
the means to effectively defend
themselves against this war of choice
from russia as well as to do everything
we can with very significant resources
to care for ukrainian people the best of
our ability inside ukraine those who've
been forced to flee outside of ukraine
to meet their humanitarian needs
and the goal
is the same
it's to end this aggression
it's to save lives
and to prevent more ceaseless senseless
bloodshed
as part of that we also have to see to
it that this war
does not expand our goal is to end the
war
not to expand it uh including
potentially expand it to nato territory
we want to make sure that it's not
prolonged to the best of our ability
otherwise it's going to turn
even deadlier
involve more people and
i think
potentially even
make things harder to resolve in ukraine
itself
so as the foreign secretary said we have
exactly the the same perspective on that
introducing in our case
american service members
in ukraine on ukrainian territory or
soil
or american pilots
into ukrainian airspace whether on a
full or on a limited basis
would almost certainly lead to direct
conflict between the united states
between nato
and russia and that would expand the
conflict it would prolong it it would
make it much uh more deadlier than it
already is
and that would be neither in the
interest of our countries nor in the
interest of ukraine
i can't speak for nato obviously but
we've heard the same
message from its secretary general jens
stoltenberg
nick wadhams and bloomberg
thanks very much mr secretary first for
you on venezuela can you just tell us
whether the u.s is considering
easing sanctions on venezuela to get its
oil absent of any progress on the
negotiations of the opposition and then
second for both of you on the sanctions
in the end game um you mentioned
foreign secretary that putin must fail
uh so is it your strategy now to
essentially exert so much pressure on
the russian people
uh oligarchs around vladimir putin
so that russia will essentially as under
secretary nuland said yesterday might
rise up
and uh i i don't know what potentially
overthrow him do you believe now
that it's simply impossible for the
united states to have
a productive or stable relationship with
russia if vladimir putin remains in
power
either during or once this conflict is
over thank you
i'm happy to start uh nick with regard
to venezuela um we have a set of
interests with uh venezuela they include
of course
supporting uh the dembrick aspirations
aspirations of the venezuelan people
they include
securing the release of americans who
are unjustly detained there
and happily last night as you heard two
americans gustavo cardenas and jorge
fernandez
were released they had been wrongfully
detained they're now reunited with their
families and it's also true that we have
uh an interest globally
in maintaining a steady supply of energy
including through our diplomatic efforts
so all of these things
come to bear when it comes to venezuela
as well as to
other countries around the world where
we have a multiplicity of interests
and use diplomacy to try to to advance
them and again i have to say i'm very
pleased
that diplomacy brought two unjustly
detained americans home just last night
we will never let up
anywhere
at any time in the efforts to bring
americans unjustly detained
back
home
we're very clear that our objective is
for putin to fail
in ukraine
this unwarranted act of aggression
must not succeed and there will be
terrible consequences if it did succeed
for european and global security and the
purpose of the sanctions is to
debilitate the russian economy to stop
putin being able to fund his war machine
from money gained from the oil and gas
industry
and from the technology
that he's been able to make available so
one of the things we've done
as well as putting huge sanctions on
banks and on the swift system
is put in export control so that the
technology that was being used to
develop the military-industrial complex
is simply not going to russia
it's also worth saying that we've seen
huge action from the private sector
whether it's mcdonald's or other
companies and one of the issues in
russia is of course the lack of free
media the fact that the russian people
aren't being told the truth but they
will be seeing now by the fact that
shops are closing they're not able to
get the goods that they were able to get
exactly the implications that putin's
aggression is in ukraine
is having for russia
the people around him the military
leaders the
ordinary people of russia might rise up
against him so
well
let me say a couple things to this first
i think it's important to
remember that
throughout
this crisis created by
by putin and russia
we've sought to provide
possible offerings
to
president putin
he's the only one who can decide whether
or not to take them so far every time
there's been an opportunity to do just
that he's pressed the accelerator
and continued down
this horrific road
that
he's been pursuing
he has a clear plan right now to
brutalize ukraine
but
to what end
because when it comes to an end game the
big question in the first instance is
what is his endgame
we saw
the failures of the initial military
plan to quickly subjugate the country
that's failed
so
he's now turning to a strategy of
laying waste to
to the population centers
to the country
if his goal is to impose some kind of
puppet regime by displacing the existing
government and um putting in place one
to his liking
i think it's pretty evident by the
response of the ukrainian people uh that
they will never accept that
and if he tries to enforce such a puppet
uh regime by keeping russian forces in
ukraine
it will be a long
bloody drawn out mess through which
russia will continue to suffer
uh grievously
so our response um continues to be
to do everything we possibly can to make
sure that the ukrainians have the means
to defend themselves to make sure we do
everything we possibly can to exert
uh pressure on russia and on putin to
change course
to do everything we possibly can of
course to support those who are
suffering as a result of russia's
actions
ultimately
i'm absolutely convinced that
putin will fail
and russia will
suffer a strategic defeat no matter what
short-term tactical gains it may make
in ukraine
as we've said
before
you can
win a battle
uh but uh that doesn't mean you win the
war on the contrary uh you can take a
city but you can't take the hearts and
minds of its people and ukrainians are
demonstrating that
every single day so
i am convinced that
we will see
a strategic defeat
of
president putin the propositions he's
put forward uh we'll accomplish this by
backing ukrainians in their fight
by remaining united in holding russia
accountable
through the devastating sanctions the
diplomatic isolation and other measures
and we've already seen that russia has
failed in its chief objectives
it's not been able to hold ukraine
it's not going to be able to hold
ukraine in the long term again no matter
what the tactical victories it may
achieve are
liz was just saying
economically the measures that we've
taken
have
erased 30 years of progress integrating
russia into the world
this dramatic exodus
of virtually every international company
from russia
continues as we speak and that is having
a profound impact not just today but
over the long term
so
i think what we're
looking at is whether or not uh
president putin will decide to try to
finally cut the losses that he's
inflicted on himself
and inflicted on the russian people we
can't decide that for him
all that we can do is to continue this
extraordinary effort
to
increase the pressure on him
increase our support for ukraine
and
achieve
what what we all want which is the
independence of ukraine and a
defeat for
president putin because these methods
are a fundamental challenge not only to
ukraine
but to the very principles of
international peace and security that
our countries
have fought
and worked to establish over many
decades that's what it's at risk here
we're committed to defending them
we're committed to standing for them
until
we succeed in making it clear
that
they will hold and
putin's efforts to undermine them will
fail
finally can we have david charter of the
times please
thank you very much indeed um first
question to secretary blinken um
it's actually it's been uh reported in
the wall street journal today that um
saudi arabia and the uae have both
rebuffed attempts to set up
conversations with president biden
in recent days
what does this snub tell us about
relations with these two important gulf
states and what do you what's your
message to try and encourage them to
produce
more oil during this crisis
and to the foreign secretary please um
you said a few days ago that you would
absolutely support
individual britons going to
ukraine to take part in the fighting
we have reports now of up to four
british
serving soldiers
who are in ukraine possibly are on their
way
what information can you give us about
that please and has your message changed
as far as they're concerned and i might
just add that in your opening comments
you did talk about asking nato allies to
invest more does that mean we can expect
that you will push for more defense
spending in the uk thank you
thank you very much uh with regard to
the gulf countries um
first
we share very important interests with
them uh from deterring iranian
aggression and iranian-enabled attacks
whether it's against saudi arabia
against the emirates
we share a strong interest in supporting
the un-backed efforts to end the war in
yemen
we share an interest in ensuring
the stability of global energy supplies
and we've had very constructive
engagements with uh with those interests
in mind uh just yesterday
uh i spent a fair bit of time on the
phone with my um emirati counterpart
we're all
talking regularly i've regularly met
with my saudi counterpart including in
munich just uh just a few weeks ago
the president president biden spoke with
king salman of saudi arabia last month
in a discussion that set out a very
expansive agenda and we're now pursuing
that agenda with our senior saudi
counterparts so they set out a
work plan for for us we're we're moving
forward on it
and i might add we can do all of this
while doing what we said we would do
from the outset which was centering
human rights
in in our foreign policy
these priorities are not mutually
exclusive
in fact for us
they're very much complementary we're
not going to separate our values from
our interests
we've made that clear in everything
we've done but we're working
productively constructively
with those countries i think there was
just an announcement
a short while ago as i'm not sure if
it's been made publicly yet about
emirati support for increased production
when it comes to uh to opec plus
which i think is a
an important thing to stabilize global
energy markets to make sure that there
remains an abundant supply of energy
around the world
i have been very clear that the travel
advice from the united kingdom is not to
go to ukraine in fact i repeated that
message at the foreign affairs committee
earlier this week there are better ways
of helping the efforts in ukraine
namely donating to the dec appeal
what i said the other week was
expressing support for the ukrainian
cause they are fighting a just war and
we are doing all we can to support them
on the subject of defense spending the
reality is across the west we haven't
spent enough on defense for a number of
years and we have seen a build up of
military capability from russia in terms
of both technology and numbers and i
welcome the fact that germans are now
increasing their defense spending
we're seeing other countries follow suit
i'm not going to preempt
any future discussions between the
chancellor and the defense secretary but
as well as conventional defense we also
need to step up our efforts in areas
like information
one of the things that the united states
united kingdom have been doing
is using information
exposing intelligence we have to call
out putin's playbook and i think that's
been very important but the fact is that
the united kingdom abandoned
its information unit at the end of the
cold war and the russians didn't abandon
their information unit so we need to
making sure that on every possible front
whether it's conventional defense
whether it's technology
or whether indeed it's
information we are able to out-compete
our adversaries
thank you all very much thank you
thank you very much
thank you everyone
that's not true
you